welcome back to Hannity all right former
Obama CIA director and deep State actor
John Brennan he testified on the hill
yesterday in a closed door hearing about
the infamous letter falsely claiming
that Hunter Biden's laptop was Russian
disinformation and according to the
house Judiciary Committee chairman Jim
Jordan his testimony confirmed it was
all a political stunt take a look at
this he said for a four-hour interview
Jesse and he further confirmed that this
thing was all political we expect public
servants not to use their title to
influence an election and it was so
political when it was all done this
talking point they wanted to give Joe
Biden for that final debate with
President trump it was so political
now his testimony comes on the heels of
a disturbing report this week that
active CIA employees may have been
working to find more officials former
officials to sign on to the phony letter
here with react reaction just the
news.com editor-in-chief John Solomon
and Fox News contributor Miranda Devine
John let's start with you
um well I guess this is the the talking
point they wanted to give Biden in that
debate that was upcoming against Donald
Trump uh John Brennan we know he
responded he would sign on to this
letter in 19 minutes when I believe it
was Morrell that wrote him
yeah listen and he and Morel told him
what his goal was he wanted to give the
debate or the president a talking point
Joe Biden the talking point to try to
blunt what Donald Trump was going to say
about the hunter by laptop it was all
political and we now know from the email
saying just forget the testimony for a
second which is just as important we
know from the email exchanges this was a
political operation it was designed to
impact the last job interview Americans
got with their two presidential
candidates and keep the hunter Biden
laptop from being considered by the
American voter before the election
you know and Miranda it was your paper
the New York Post that broke the hunter
Biden laptop story you wrote the book
the laptop from hell what's interesting
the level of involvement now we have the
CIA involved in this we have former
Intel officials involved in this uh but
we also know that the FBI was out there
uh meeting weekly with big tech
companies telling them they may be
victims of a misinformation campaign
that may be about Joe and Hunter Biden
but they had that laptop in December of
2019 and John Solomon told me this week
that they had authenticated it in the
spring of 2020 so they knew what they
were doing it seems like the FBI and the
CIA were putting cinder blocks on the
scales of a presidential election
doesn't it
absolutely they conspired with the Biden
campaign to deceive the American voter
and that as Mike Pompeo said about the
involvement of now we find out at least
one CIA employee in soliciting
signatures to sign that dishonest letter
alleging that the laptop information was
Russian disinformation uh Mike Pompeo
said that is dangerous for democracy you
you see now we've got the CIA engaged in
a political operation to rig the
election we also knew that the FBI was
doing that because they pre-bunked our
story they knew it was coming because
they were spying on Rudy Giuliani so
they went to Big Tech and in these
weekly meetings they pre-bunked our
story they said expect a story about
Hunter Biden to come in October it's
hacked information from the Russians and
you know I don't have any faith in John
Brennan or James Clapper who is also
going to go and speak in these closed
door sessions with House Republicans
because they are trained liars and we
know that both John Brennan the former
CIA director and James Clapper have
already lied before Congress and there
was never any sanctions for them Mike
Pompeo is right this is really dangerous
to have this kind of political activity
going on inside the CIA and the FBI and
if there was one CIA employee you know
that there were others well you got to
ask John this is two presidential
elections in a row where the Deep state
is involved two with John Brennan uh and
then of course I don't know if Clapper
is involved in this I would not be
surprised uh but if he goes in if he was
if he says put my name on this after 19
minutes with no investigative work at
all no knowledge at all as to the
veracity and authenticity of the laptop
uh that is is that not an in-kind
donation to President Biden or then
candidate Biden
well that is the question that the
Federal Election Commission currently is
investigating just a few weeks ago they
told parties in the case that they have
an open matter under review that's a
fancy word for the FCC saying it's under
investigation that this may count as a a
political contribution uh and it wasn't
recorded or disclosed to the American
public so that investigation is ongoing
by the way that that opened just a
couple of weeks before Jim Jordan and
the house intelligence committee and
others made these bombshell Revelations
these Revelations will inform that in a
bigger way I will make one other
argument it's actually three straight
elections that the intelligence
committee have uh involved got involved
in 2012 Mike Morrell the same guy that
in 2020 organized a letter in 2016 was
the first intelligence official to come
out and say Donald Trump might be a
Russian asset in 2012 as Barack Obama
was trying to survive the Benghazi
scandal and get reelected he edited the
talking points by his own testimony to
take out the idea that it was a terror
attack which the CIA had confirmed and
instead I'd leave the impression that
maybe it was an anti-muslim video going
across Europe that did it so three
consecutive elections we had
manipulation by our intelligence
community
all right so Miranda we have former
Intel officials uh but one of the people
that was involved in leading this effort
uh is the Secretary of State and his
name is Tony blinken he played a very
big role in this what should happen to
him here
well he perhaps to be impeached at least
to be shamed he should not be in that
job when he was a an advisor to Joe
Biden in his campaign he called Mike
Morrell and Mike Morrell has testified
under oath that that Lincoln's uh call
to discuss the New York Post our story
about the laptop was the impetus was
what triggered him to go and get that
letter written and he also Anthony
blinken sent to Mike Morrell a few hours
after that phone call an article from
USA Today alleging that the FBI was
investigating whether it was Russian
disinformation all of this was a lie and
in fact John Ratcliffe then the dni he
came out with a statement saying there
is absolutely no evidence that this is
anything to do with Russia that this is
a Russian plant or a Russian
disinformation and that was in response
to Adam Schiff and others of the 51
Fanning out across the media to say that
this looks like a Kremlin plot that was
our story and that gave the Fig leaf for
the rest of the media to ignore our
story and it gave the Fig leaf for big
Tech to bury it and censor it John thank
you Miranda thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else